for those of you that live under a rock
or have a life outside of Counterstrike
last week one of the game's most elusive
skins was finally obtained a factory new
stat Trak 661 AK-47 however despite
early reports that the skin was going to
sell for a whopping $1 million it seems
that the mysterious owner has just
doubled that
[Music]
price all right so the coveted 661 is
shaping up to be the biggest sale and
not only Counter-Strike history but
video game history but before we get
into how that's the case and what this
means for Counterstrike what is the 661
well the case harden AK-47 is one of the
ogs released alongside the arms deal
update that brought us skins in the
first place certain knives would get
this style as well as future gloves and
other guns and it quickly became a fan
favorite for a few reasons first off
they're rare they're not easily unboxed
or crafted and as the laws of supply and
demand will have it that increases value
now aesthetically speaking they're just
dope as hell just like the real world
Act of case Harding metal these skins
have a beautiful metallic rainbow of
gold orange pink and blue on top of that
case hardens are unique patterns meaning
the coloring and positioning can vary
depending on the pattern index you get
the pattern index in Counter-Strike
ranges from 1 to 1,000 and the community
has created several different categories
for patterns that share similar
characteristics there are several of
these categories for case hardens but
only two of them are important to this
story gold gem and blue gem a gold gem
will have a high amount of gold patterns
on the skin where a blue gem you guessed
it will have more blue but blue gems are
incredibly rare to come by and certain
pattern indexes within that category are
considered much more aesthetically
pleasing which raises the value even
more and at the top of that hierarchy is
the pattern index 661 or scar pattern
blue gem which is distinguished by its
large blue pattern visible along the top
rail of the gun now 66 ones have been
unboxed or crafted in trade-ups before
some have even been the highest quality
in Factory new or Stat trck but in the
history of Counterstrike none have ever
been both that was until last week where
do I see it
noly f the $1 million AK
unboxer yes after more than 10 years of
its potential existence a factory new
stat track 661 scar pattern AK has
finally been unboxed pretty much
Christmas for all CS skin enthusiasts
now the owner of set skin apparently
crafted this in a trade-up contract but
they've been rather mysterious about
their identity and for good reason this
skin has been valued by Traders at $1
million for that kind of money I'd be
pretty damn cautious as well most other
66 ons that aren't a unicorn like this
one go from anywhere between 100K to
400k depending on where the stickers on
it and other stuff like that but once
again there is only one like this known
in exist distance so most people knew
that this puppy was going to go on the
market for a pretty penny however the
owner of this skin Finally Revealed
himself and dropped the bomb that he was
going to accept offers for much much
more confirmed by zipple who will be
helping with the sale of the skin the
owner already has two offers of a
million and as a result he is setting
the buyout to 2 million bucks two
million dollar for a digital skin in a
video game is just a little bit
ridiculous if you ask me but the don't
get it twisted there are people wealthy
people willing to drop that cash and if
someone does decide to skip the whole
bidding war and drop a cool 2 mill on
this skin it will be the biggest sale in
Counter-Strike history but it still
won't be the most expensive skin you see
despite the Rarity and insane price tag
the 661 is technically runner up to
another blue gem behold the blue gem
carit whose owner new rage has already
turned down an offer of 1.5 mil million
he told me to reach out to him with an
offer of
1.2 million in Bitcoin and I'm not
talking about USD I'm talking about
Euros which converts to 1.5 million USD
for similar reasons to the 661 AK this
camit is valued so highly due to the
player side being almost entirely blue
and that there's only one on the market
but here's the thing if the 661 gets
sold for more or bought out at $2
million what is does that mean for the
knife that's already supposed to be
valued for more well this is where we
get into the unknowns of the story new
ra has held on to his crit for years now
so it's unclear whether or not he
actually intends to sell it but if the
661 sells for more than 1.5 million you
can bet your ass he's going to raise the
price of that ramit the question is how
much and although I mentioned that these
wealthy collectors do exist we've never
seen a sale like this go through the
highest sale for a single skin
previously has been 400k so this is a
pretty damn big jump so the question is
will anyone actually spend this much on
a video game cosmetic and if so how do I
explain it to my dad without giving him
a heart
attack what's the most you spend SK the
most I've spent on his skin I have like
a few like I don't have like expensive
things but I have a few things that like
I was like oh cool that went up a bit
like my um my PR streams are like I got
them at like $30 $40 and they're like I
think I could be very wrong right now
but last time I check there like 150
bucks